just when he went for this Knight xd4
that he just wants to make a draw yeah
I'm also fine with that I mean now I can
just give everything on uh for tomorrow
and then relax after that okay did you
realize yesterday during the game
that there was something wrong with him
yeah I didn't feel like it didn't feel
like he was having a lot of energy I
felt that but I didn't think he was
unwell yeah I I hope he recovers for
tomorrow
my final question there's a lot of media
attention here all your fans are outside
are you getting used to dealing with
this how is this uh affecting you on
your day-to-day schedule
yeah I'm definitely getting used to this
and yeah it's good to see so many people
um
you know following chess and uh yeah
chess is definitely getting popular so
in that way I'm very happy thanks a lot